[Musique]
bon joueur avec l'arche est
particulièrement les pieds ont
effectivement on va parler des pires
reuters êtes adjoint à la ville de saint
pierre
les élus de la ville d'art et d'histoire
qui en ont assez de ces nuisances liées
au transport de matériaux la poussière
le bruit la circulation
la liste est longue je ne sais pas
seulement les le conseil municipal qui
en a assez sont le reflet de ce que nous
dit la population ce qu'on ressent à
cette population
et ça fait suite à un énième accident
copé est mortelle il ya à peu près dix
jours il ne pouvait pas rester sans
réaction pas apprendre ça nous sommes
élus depuis deux ans maintenant ça fait
deux ans que nous nous battons pour
sécuriser les lieux et trouver des
solutions pour pallier à ces nuisances
causées par l'activité des carrières
alors cette situation liée à la
circulation des camionneurs sur saint
pierre
cette situation des buts tôt le matin en
dépit pourtant d'arrêtés municipaux pour
tenter de réguler ce trafic tout à fait
alors c'est pas tous les chauffeurs de
camions qui sont qui sont en cause
certains qui ne respectent pas la loi
comme certains tout ne respectent pas le
code de la route et il y en a arrêté
municipal qui interdit la circulation
des poids lourds entre 22h et 5h du
matin mais se trouve que pour pouvoir
gagner du temps petit première changer
leur carrière non six chauffeurs les
camions passent à 2h 3h 4h du matin vous
allez tenter de les arrêter de les
interpeller sur cette question de leur
dire le mal qu'il cause par exemple
assez scolaire qui doivent à aller
travailler
nous avons déjà essayé de nous devons
déjà toute une pédagogie par nous
seulement les autres communes ici pas
lité également il faut vouloir
reconnaître ça fait 40 ans que ça existe
à saint pierre et il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que les
sanctions qui sont prévus pour un arrêté
municipal de ces de ce type si nous
soucier de catégorie 1 c'est à dire que
ces 17 euros ouais t'es pas très
dissuasif ou respecter la loi
séduisant se prolonge toute la journée
avec la circulation toujours la
traversée du bourg vous parlez
de jusqu'à 200 rotations chaque jour il
ya plus de 250 des dernières analyses
que j'ai ici nous confère qu'il ya plus
de 250 passages des camions par jour
dans sur le littoral nord karim il à
vous évoquez avec ses camions une triple
peine avec les risques de la pollution
par les microparticules nous avons déjà
la brume du sahara qui connaît qui
provoque des dégâts que nous connaissons
la combustion du gas-oil et la poussière
des carrières sans compter les chaussées
habillé dans le poids le passage des
camions et qui creuserait un problème au
wiki routine bien entendu on va quand
même rappeler que st pierre et ses
carrières c'est pas loin de la moitié de
la production peut être même plus de la
plus que la moitié c'est 60% de la
production avec la fermeture des
carrières du diamant soixante pour cent
de de la production des matériaux de
construction de la martinique par
titouan bosque a rien qui sont installés
à saint pierre alors il ya eu cette
notion la semaine dernière vous
interpeller tout le monde que voulez
vous exactement
alors nous sommes soucieux et nous
sommes responsables de la sécurité de la
santé des pieds au teint de pas en nous
nos mandats mais nous pouvons agir à
notre avec les moyens que nous avons et
d'autres doivent agir ici nous
n'interpellons pas nous ne pourrons pas
le faire
là c'est évident que ça dure 40 alors
que les pires hautain et appelle les
autorités tout à fait non la septième a
son rôle à jouer
les tares son rôle à jouer et les
parlementaires aussi ont leur rôle à
jouer parce que avec cette norme de
qu'ils le volent ils eurent qu'est ce
que vous voulez vous voulez qu'on
élargisse des voix non je prends
l'exemple des parlementaires qui bientôt
n'auront les incitatifs quel que soit le
candidat quelque chose que vous
demanderez ils diront oui ils sont
encore non c'est normal on veut qu'ils
se prennent du problème éthique
comprennent ils savent ça fait 40 ans il
le sent mieux dans mais vous savez là
dedans
la plupart des candidats viennent nous
voir dans le nord nous parler du
développement du nom mais ici on sait
très bien qu'un député ne fait pas le
développement du nombre de députés
votent des lois et avec des lois avec
des modifications de existantes
ils peuvent être âgé au sur le cadre de
vie des pieds au teint je prends
l'exemple celle ci député martiniquais
s'associe à d'autres députés de doute
coville qui sont traversés par ou ou
d'inactivité paulien comme la nôtre font
des procédures mais la loi une offre
contraignante sur la solution riz à la
sauce hier je prends l'exemple
stablement des carrières par exemple les
carrières actuellement elles sont
soumises à une taxe si les activités
polluantes d'accord qui vise tout le sol
français
cette taxe est perçue par l'état
français il ya une taxe qui peut être
perçue directement par les collectivités
locales ou la ville entre autres ce qui
s'appelle une taxe c'est là qu'ils
débloquent aériennes et donc nous
demandons nous députés à nous
parlementaires nos sénateurs de
permettre aux villes comme ça tient pas
seulement cinquième gain de trois villes
comme sa tendre enfance qui peuvent
percevoir cette taxe il leur permet
d'avoir une activité d'améliorer le
cadre vide de nos administrés depuis
cette motion est ce que certains
candidats vous ont déjà appeler pour se
renseigner sur la situation
alors je veux préciser qu'une chose nous
avons aussi dans cette motion lors du
vote de cette motion pris l'engagement
de ne soutenir aucun candidat qui ne
tiendra pas compte de notre motion ça
c'est une première chose
hier nous avons reçu à soutenir
l'innovation et tenir les candidats qui
ne vont pas rendre compte
la motion dans laquelle l'on serait de 4
ans mais qu'elle est revenue en garde
toujours élus individuellement vous ne
soutiendrait pas j'ai pas compris mais
vous avez vu le ce qui s'est passé avec
nicolas hulot ce qui a créé les
grenelles de l'environnement nicolas il
a fait une procédure
il a demandé à tous les candidats aux
élections présidentielles de s'imprégner
de son de son dossier de le signer et
tous
en fait tous ceux qui t'ont stieg et ça
aboutit à brunel de la violente parce
que c'est un engagement qui avait été
pris très bien nous nous demandons donc
deux choses par le moto aux candidats
parlementaires un de permettre qu'une
procédure soit mise en place
pour activer cette fameuse taxe sur les
pollutions aériennes
et la deuxième chose de permettre de
changer le type 2
digoin de contraventions qu'une ville
peut être avant sur un arrêté municipal
comme celui ses dires et la fameuse
question du transport par barge on en
est où là aussi c'est le vieux serpent
de mer qui de temps en temps aussi son
apparition
et puis on ne veut pas de ce projet
finalement c'est pas que neveu qui n'est
pas du genre qui ne veulent pas tout le
monde en parle ça mais il ya une célèbre
marque de fruyt où il y avait un slogan
qui dit ce sont ceux qui en parlent le
plus qui en mangent le must là chaque
fois qu'il ya des élections là qui
viennent et puis que nous en parle mais
qui sont maintenant précise monsieur
planchette talent ne veut pas de ce
transport de barges vu qu'on en parle
depuis tellement longtemps plus de 40
ans le problème c'est qu'on veut opposer
les gens aux autres on veut opposer les
carriers aux transporteurs on veut
opposer la population aux transporteurs
en fait on veut opposer la population
aux courriers n'ont rien eu sauf alors
que alors non seulement entre deux
continents c'est comme notre démarche a
fait ça fait joli sur le tableau non
continuer à former
il faut mettre tout le monde en
partenaire sur ce dossier c'est à dire
que je prends l'exemple et y être
constructeurs aux constructeurs de
matériaux sont la solution si on les
écarte de cette solution sur les écoles
du transport le temps de forger défense
des bâtiments si on les écoles vous et
moi même c'est que si tout le monde agit
comme religieux car j'ai grandi en
entendant sa mémoire de 50 ans donc je
suis passé à autre chose de changer
gandhi dans moi aussi je me suis battu
pour qu'il y ait un mur antibruit au
collège je sais que j'étais en troisième
1 je tenais de bach ou qui est venu en
tee-shirt donc je connais le le point
parfaitement
j'ai perdu mon première d'une visite à
17,5 en dehors de la région d'hakkari la
région d'hakkari mais celle qui est le
plus touché par les asthmatiques
oui donc il faut que nous agissions et
c'est tout le monde fait comme vous dit
on pour le dossier on l'aimé parce que
il faut que ce plancher
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
maintenant n'est pas seulement des
carrières avec
la motion a été votée on va voir ce que
ça a donné lâché bleus le schéma des
carrières avec l'état implique qu'il a
déjà les élus qui sont concernés quand
est-ce qu'on le reverra ce schéma des
carrières n'en a parlé aussi une dizaine
d'années je suis allé prier plus
particulier en 2018
ouais dans un an donc qu'est ce qu'on
peut entendre ce que nous faisons
actuellement c'est pouvoir travailler
sur ces dossiers à pente et se nomme de
solutions il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
faire mieux car c'est une activité
importante non seulement pour la région
car il mais pour le reste de la
martinique parce que le problème il est
là il y a beaucoup de nuisances mais
c'est aussi un pôle de développement un
pôle d'attraction tout mais quelle pôle
de rayonnement mais dans le monde et des
avantages et les inconvénients
maintenant il faut trouver des solutions
qui permettent de minimiser il ya des
solutions qu'on est est-il transpole
breuvage a été testée en 2008 eric
hudson par semaine réduit de plus de 4%
c'est incroyable dans la solution de
contrôle l honneur des solutions
étudiants qu'il ya des décideurs qui se
met en place
il suffit qu'ils aient des commissions
qu'il ya qu'à faut qu'on on a déjà
essayé de continuer mais nous avons fait
notre travail nous montre que nous
épater nous étions déjà dans
l'opposition c'est le chef du conseil
municipal nous nous avions défendu ce
dossier
il est temps que les décideurs des
diapos locke la 7è nous invitons
d'ailleurs le président de la 7ème
monsieur alfred mylne à venir si vous
placez à constater des choses d'accord
dernière question on n'en parle pas
beaucoup les nuisances au niveau du
paysage ces carrières aux gratte la
montagne pour fournir des matériaux pour
la construction des maisons
martiniquaise
mais en même temps ça dénature ce si
joli paysage que représente saint pierre
tout à fait tout à fait on va laisser
faire on continue non il va falloir il
va justement il y à une commission qui
va ce qui se réunit qui déterminera en
fonction du p lus
je ne sais pas non plus
comme rezai se demande ce n'est pas
seulement en cinq secondes qu'on va
pouvoir déterminer un schéma dit
carrière il ya des commissions qui
scanne us il ya des gens qui étudient à
des urbanistes
il ya des spécialistes de la pollution
il ya tout le monde qui se réunit dans
une commission et qui décide
cette décision ces décisions seront
prises en 2018 donc pour le moment ceux
qui souffrent c'est quand même les pieds
au teint merci d'avoir été avec nom
hervé planchette on rappelle que vous
êtes élu à la ville de saint-pierre
hésité avec nos sites à cette motion
concernant les nuisances
il ya l'activité des camionneurs et des
carrières à sakhir merci bonne journée
merci beaucoup
[Musique]